y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva temporada
de kobe 19 la semana en américa el
espacio de france 24 en el que hacemos
un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 10 si no había continuación
algunos de los temas que vamos a tratar
en este episodio
vamos a comenzar esta nueva temporada
poniéndonos al día en torno a la
pandemia de kobe 19 en nuestro
continente por supuesto para ello
estaremos conversando con varios de
nuestros corresponsales desde canadá
hasta magallanes quienes nos contarán
cómo está la situación en torno a los
contagios al avance de los planes de
vacunación y sobre el avance de la
variante omicron en cada uno de estos
países en nuestra habitual consulta con
el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
conversaremos sobre las novedades que
hay después de varias investigaciones
sobre la variante omicron también la
propuesta de la gripa lización de la
pandemia que ha hecho el gobierno de
españa' es esto viable y les vamos a
explicar por qué hay un aumento en el
número de hospitalizaciones entre los
menores de edad vamos a comenzar lo
hacemos entonces con cifras para
actualizarnos veamos cómo está el
panorama global en cuanto al avance de
la pandemia de kobe 19 en esta
oportunidad como les estaba diciendo
vamos a ver números globales de esta
tercera semana de lo que va corrido del
2022 el número de casos reportados de
kobe 19 supera los 3 43 millones 385 mil
casos un poco más de esta cifra ya para
los próximos días los fallecidos superan
ya los 5 millones 500 mil estos según el
conteo de la universidad johns hopkins
bueno y saludo hasta ahora al doctor de
carlos eduardo pérez el médico
infectólogo y asesor científico de
france 24 ya está con nosotros para
nuestra habitual consulta la primera de
esta nueva temporada del programa doctor
bienvenido como siempre un gusto tenerlo
en el programa y comienzo preguntándole
por los avances que hay en torno a las
investigaciones de la variante o micro
aunque novedades hay sobre esta variante
que ya es la predominante en gran parte
del mundo
hola santiago mira una de las cosas que
hemos aprendido
es su alta contagiosidad es un virus que
ha adquirido mutaciones que le
incrementa la capacidad infectada de
humano a humano también este virus tiene
una capacidad de infectar las vías
respiratorias superiores por eso su
síntoma principal es el dolor de
garganta la molestia y es muy mucho
menos probable que afecte los pulmones
aunque si los afecta y también que esta
variante o micro es una variante 15
rápido las personas antes tenemos
enfermos duraban una semana o semanas
después de la exposición ahora es el
periódico acción mucho más fuerte eso
quiere decir que una persona que se pone
en contacto con haber alguien enfermo en
12 días ya empieza a manifestarse
doctor varios sectores buscan tratar la
pandemia del cobi 19 como una endemia la
ms ha dicho que esta no es la solución
para poner fin a esta crisis a nivel
global que es una endemia qué
diferencias tiene con una pandemia qué
es lo que hemos vivido en los últimos
meses esto entonces se está poniendo un
escenario como endemia contra la
pandemia qué significa esto
recordemos que una pandemia es cuando
todos somos susceptibles y todos nos
enfermamos y tenemos la capacidad de
enfermarnos de la misma forma en una
enfermedad endémica es una enfermedad
que permanece estable digamos permanece
circulando dentro de la comunidad pero
algunas personas no se enferman gran sea
porque están vacunadas o porque tienen
defensas naturales contra la enfermedad
o porque toman medicamentos que
previenen enfermedad o la situación de
una endemia es que digamos nuestro
comportamiento va a estar siempre
paralelo con mtv lo que pasa es que
ahora es muy temprano porque no sabemos
si hay nuevas variantes que puedan
suceder que puedan aumentar la
virulencia es decir su capacidad de
enfermar y tenemos un retraso en la
vacunación hay algunos países que lo
tienen adelantado pero recordemos que
esto no es una acción local eso tiene
una acción coordinada en todo el globo
terráqueo para que todos estemos
inmunizados y logremos entre una fase
endémica yo creo que son anuncios un
poco precoces y probablemente al final
en el segundo semestre este año si
podemos hablar de una situación entiendo
doctor otro término que queda sobre la
mesa fue propuesto por el presidente del
gobierno español pedro sanz sánchez el
habla de la gripa lización de la
pandemia diciendo claramente que los
científicos y los médicos son los que
saben de este tema pero él ha indicado
que ya puede tratarse la situación como
si fuera una gripe normal es esto
posible que piensa usted al respecto
no es algo desafortunado que considere
eso porque lo que nos dice es que el
comportamiento es distinto en las
personas vacunadas donde la infección
puede ser leve pero hay pacientes que
incluso estando vacunados pueden tener
algún tipo de enfermedad que requiere
atención médica pero definitivamente una
gran proporción que no estaba una y
estas personas y lo estamos viendo en la
actualidad en la región pueden enfermar
o llegar al cuidado intensivo es decir
que en una gripa no lleva contención es
un poco de simplificar el problema que
tenemos y por eso es tan importante
vacunar nos en el momento en que todos
nos proponemos pero no regiones
globalmente si podríamos hablar de que
sea una situación endémica de una
infección respiratoria pero todavía no
es hora de hacer esos anuncios
doctor otra controversia que hay en la
comunidad internacional y en la
comunidad científica y médica es la
cuarta dosis ante el rápido avance de la
variante o micro en países como israel y
chile en la región de américa latina ya
comenzaron a inocular algunos sectores
de la sociedad con esta cuarta dosis qué
información hay en torno a la
efectividad de esta cuarta dosis que
cuidado se deben tener qué
particularidades tiene con respecto a
las otras tres dosis que ya muchos hemos
accedido
bueno hay que tener en cuenta dos cosas
esta es una iniciativa que se ha hecho
por regiones y se ha priorizado en
grupos de personas por ejemplo que tiene
ninguno supresión que toman medicamentos
que bajan las defensas y ellos pueda que
requieran dosis adicionales todavía no
está establecido cuál es el tiempo para
esa cuarta los recientes estudios han
mostrado una cuarta dosis al parecer no
mejora más allá de la respuesta que se
logra con tres dosis sin embargo estas
infecciones son estas informaciones son
preliminares por ahora que debemos hacer
completar la pauta completa que son tres
dosis y si es un amor una inmunización
con monodosis tener una dosis adicional
de refuerzo y la cuarta dosis no está
establecido todavía ese grupo de
personas y al cuánto tiempo podemos ser
un poco cauto es esperar un poco más de
la información y hasta ahora están
haciéndose los estudios clínicos pero al
parecer ese beneficio va a ser marginal
y necesitemos más bien revacunar nos con
dosis para otros variando
doctor para el cierre que cambio en la
dinámica de la pandemia que ahora vemos
un incremento de menores de edad
hospitalizados por kobe 19
la alta tasa de contagio santiago este
es un virus que antes conocíamos que una
sola persona infectados cuando iniciamos
en la pandemia cuando llegó la variante
delta una persona infectada entre 6 a 8
personas pero ahora se calcula que eso
es incrementado dos o cuatro veces más
es decir que una persona puede infectar
a 16 20 30 personas eso son números
increíbles eso quiere decir que la
población infantil que no está vacunada
va a tener mayor número de chance
exposición al virus y por ende
desarrollar síntomas respiratorios
algunos de ellos niños por ejemplo niños
con obesidad con comorbilidades con
inmunosupresión pueden desarrollar una
enfermedad grave por eso es llamado a
los padres y ya que se está abriendo la
vacunación en la región en niños para
que lleven sus niños a vacunar porque si
bien puede ser una infección leve en
ellos en algunos no lo es y si no va
curamos nuestros niños no cortamos la
cadena de transmisión y se pueden
desarrollar nuevas variables esa es la
explicación porque tanto la población
pediátrica se está faltando el acto
doctor importante ese llamado que usted
hace importante está esta explicación
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros en
el programa hoy aquí en cómic 19 la
semana en américa vamos a seguir
hablando de la variante omicron que ha
provocado un aumento considerable en el
número de contagios de kobe 19 en el
continente americano ya lo estamos
diciendo así lo ha reiterado la
organización panamericana de la salud
que hizo un llamado a los gobiernos a
usar todas sus herramientas para evitar
su avance
como nunca antes así se propaga el virus
que genera el kobe 19 en el continente
americano esta es la más reciente
conclusión de la organización
panamericana de la salud un repunte
impulsado por el avance de la variante
omicron ante la cual la ope se pide no
bajar la guardia
aunque las infecciones por un micrón
parecen ser más leves seguimos pidiendo
precaución porque el virus se está
propagando más activamente que nunca
las vacunas nos protegen de los peores
síntomas el kobe 19 y reducen nuestras
posibilidades de requerir atención
hospitalaria es que con 72 millones de
nuevos casos registrados en la última
semana la ope se destaca el aumento en
las hospitalizaciones en eeuu y canadá
incrementos también constatados en
paraguay uruguay y argentina los picos
de infecciones afectan a colombia perú
bolivia pero sobre todo a brasil el
gigante sudamericano registró un nuevo
récord superando por primera vez los
200.000 casos diarios mientras el país
avanza con la vacunación para niños
entre los 5 y los 11 años podríamos
y
podríamos haber iniciado antes de esta
vacunación pero el ministerio de salud
se quedó discutiendo promoviendo
audiencias y otras sin utilidades y
otros sin utilidades en ecuador' un
aumento de 185 por ciento de los casos
registrados en la última semana llevaron
a quitó entrar en alerta roja ante el
preocupante panorama regional la ope se
hace un llamado a priorizar las pruebas
rápidas de antígenos para personas
sintomáticas aunque el 60% de los
habitantes de américa latina y el caribe
cuentan con un esquema completo de
vacunación el organismo urge a frenar la
propagación usando además de las vacunas
otras herramientas como el
distanciamiento las mascarillas y la
cancelación de eventos masivos ya
tenemos un poco más claro el contexto
pero vamos al terreno a los países para
ver cómo está la situación en cada uno
de ellos voy a comenzar esta ronda de
norte hacia el sur danielle faura desde
la ciudad de toronto en canadá nos
cuenta cómo está la situación en este
país adelante daños
santiago cómo está usted un saludo desde
toronto en canadá este país tiene
reportados dos millones ochocientos
cincuenta mil casos de kobe y
fallecimientos por 31 mil novecientos
ochenta casos las provincias que tienen
más casos son que ve contario y albert a
quebec ha sido muy polémico por estos
días pues pensaron en lanzar un impuesto
para personas no vacunadas más o menos
de 50 dólares canadienses no es una
realidad en un diario se pensó algo
similar pero tampoco se llegó a algún
acuerdo el primer ministro de canadá
hosting trudeau le dijo al major de
quebec que se llama françois alega que
tiene que estudiar y tener más recursos
para saber si pueden poner este impuesto
por el momento el mayor puso una medida
que si está en su poder y es que le
prohíbe la entrada a personas a
establecimientos de alcohol y de
cannabis si no están vacunadas es una
medida muy polémica pero que ya es una
realidad no se ha pensado en relajar las
medidas y se le dice a las personas que
tengan mucho cuidado que sean muy
conscientes porque hay un déficit
personal de salud de 12.000 personas que
están contagiadas de kobin también hay
que decir que en ontario ya es una
realidad el retorno a clases también el
próximo 31 de enero se va a hacer que
vuelva el aforo a ciertos
establecimientos como casinos como
salones como teatros cine más con un 50
por ciento de aforo no se puede vender
comida todavía en estos sitios pero lo
cierto es que se van relajando las
medidas porque se muestra una tendencia
estable y a la baja en contagios en
alberta es está pasando algo similar a
quebec y es que no se han tomado medidas
para relajar el confinamiento porque la
tendencia no está a la baja ni es
estable así que el primer ministro de
esta provincia que se llama jason kenny
ha dicho hasta que no veamos un cambio
en las cifras pues no vamos a hacer nada
al respecto que lo que tiene que ver con
kobe me despido con una temperatura de
menos 32 sensación de menos 32 aquí
desde ontario canadá santiago abrigarse
bien daniel de ese frío canadiense de
eeuu más de 70 millones de casos de
contagio de kobe 19 y es el país más
afectado por la pandemia para pensarla
tiene más información desde nueva york
en eeuu ahora mismo se está registrando
una media de 740 mil nuevos contagios
diarios eso es un 92 por ciento del pico
máximo que se ha alcanzado de contagios
en este país ahora mismo hay más de 70
millones de personas en eeuu que ya han
contraído la enfermedad del cob y 19 y
cerca de 863 mil personas se han
fallecido por el coronavirus las
autoridades sanitarias al gobierno
continúa insistiendo que la mejor manera
de luchar contra esta pandemia es el uso
de la mascarilla y la vacuna una campaña
de vacunación que continúa muy lenta muy
estancada con tan sólo un 65 por ciento
de la población completamente vacunado y
lo que nos estamos encontrando es que
está habiendo muchas vacunas de refuerzo
pero muy pocos primeros pinchazos porque
todavía hay mucha gente reciente que
rechaza esa vacuna la situación en el
país es bastante diferente dependiendo
del estado en la zona norte y medio
oeste encontramos que poco a poco ya se
empiezan a recuperar empieza a disminuir
el número de hospitalizaciones y de
contagios como ocurre por ejemplo en
washington o aquí en nueva york donde
las 24 horas se ha registrado un 11%
menos de contagios por 19 sin embargo la
situación es muy diferente en el sur y
en el oeste donde los contagios todavía
continúan aumentando porque allí la
variante omicron llegó más tarde y
todavía tardarán varias semanas en
recuperarse en lugares como yuta alabama
o carolina del sur los hospitales se
encuentran realmente hasta arriba y los
contagios continúan aumentando la
situación allí es bastante más
preocupante
dejamos el frío y la nieve nos vamos
hasta méxico mario' carbonell nos cuenta
sobre ese grupo de gobernadores
mexicanos que han resultado contagiados
con kobe 19 veamos la información si
esta cuarta ola parece no tener freno en
mexico esta semana se ha roto más de una
vez el récord el pasado miércoles se
tuvo el reporte más alto de contagios en
un lapso de 24 horas con más de 60 mil
500 y con estos suman ya más de cuatro y
medio millones de contagios acumulados
ciertamente el ritmo de muertes y
hospitalizaciones no es tan acelerado
como el de contagios
en muertes hay ya oficialmente
reconocidas más de 302.000 y la
hospitalización aunque se ha
incrementado se mantiene en 24% los
gobernadores de los estados no han
escapado a esta ola de contagios y esta
semana se han infectado el de jalisco y
el del estado de mexico dos de las
entidades junto con la capital del país
y el estado de tabasco que más
concentran contagios del hobbit por otra
parte ha crecido la polémica en torno de
la negativa del gobierno a vacunar a los
niños desde recursos de amparo por parte
de los padres hasta exhortos en el
congreso para incluir a los menores en
el esquema de vacunación otra
controversia es en torno del responsable
del manejo de la pandemia hugo lópez
gatell a quien un juez federal ha
ordenado investigar
posibles omisiones o negligencias que
hayan derivado en la muerte de personas
aquí en la ciudad de mexico la jefa de
gobierno claudia sheinbaum insiste en
que no va a cerrarse de nueva cuenta la
economía porque sería desastroso además
dice no es necesario el plan es acelerar
la aplicación de terceras dosis o dosis
de refuerzo de la vacuna a la población
que lo requiera vamos a terminar este
primer bloque en costa rica allí siendo
regidor desde san jose nos cuenta sobre
la decisión de las autoridades locales
de restablecer algunas restricciones
veamos los casos de kobe 19 en costa
rica empezaron a subir desde principios
de enero tras haber cerrado 2021 con
pocos casos y varios días sin reportar
fallecimientos la variante omicron es
ahora la más común según reportó el
instituto costarricense de investigación
y enseñanza en nutrición y salud los
casos diarios han vuelto a subir
registrándose cifras récord desde que
empezó la pandemia las hospitalizaciones
también han aumentado en las últimas
semanas ante esta nueva ola el gobierno
restableció algunas medidas y redobló la
supervisión del cumplimiento de las
mismas entre estas medidas está la
ampliación de una restricción vehicular
los eventos masivos deportivos y
culturales se podrán realizar pero sin
público y los funcionarios estatales
mantendrán el teletrabajo hasta ahora
costa rica ha aplicado más de 8 millones
de dosis de vacunas contra la cob y 19
con lo que el 70% de la población
tiene el esquema completo de vacunación
y un 10 por ciento tiene una tercera
dosis además los niños entre 5 y 11 años
ya están vacunando se en preparativos
para retomar un año escolar presencial
en febrero próximo las elecciones
generales del 6 de febrero podrían
celebrarse en medio del pico de la ola
por lo que el tribunal supremo de
elecciones ha pedido a la población que
respete el protocolo sanitario que
preparó junto al ministerio de salud
para el día de la votación esta semana
brasil comenzó a vacunar a los menores
de entre 5 y 11 años se suma así a la
lista de naciones latinoamericanas que
buscan proteger a los más pequeños con
la inoculación de biológicos a
continuación les presentamos un panorama
general del avance de la vacunación de
menores en nuestra región imágenes como
éstas se han vuelto cada vez más comunes
en américa latina' la lista de los
países que comienzan a vacunar a sus
niños aumenta el último en sumarse fue
brasil el país compró 20 millones de
vacunas pediátricas para aplicar en
menores de 5 a 11 años la vacunación no
será obligatoria sin embargo los
gobiernos estatal y podrán decidir si
deben haber recibido un biológico para
asistir a las escuelas a pesar de la
resistencia del presidente ya ir
bolsonaro te diré mi opinión mi hija de
11 años no se va a vacunar
el panorama es distinto en costa rica en
donde el gobierno ya exige la vacunación
de los menores convirtiéndose en el
segundo país en el mundo en tomar una
decisión de dicho calibre pero la
vacunación infantil contra el coi 19 no
es algo nuevo en la región uruguay fue
el precursor cuando comenzó la
inoculación a menores de entre 12 y 17
años con la vacuna pzifer a principios
de junio del año pasado seguido por
chile que optó por sinovac unas semanas
después
la vacunación de menores también avanza
en mexico el salvador panamá paraguay
perú república dominicana bolivia y
venezuela países como colombia argentina
o ecuador optaron por la vacunación de
niños desde los 3 años en adelante la
región también ha sido pionera en temas
de vacunación infantil cuba se convirtió
en el primer país en aplicar los
fármacos desde los 2 años desarrollamos
sobre las plataformas de vacunas
infantiles y voló dando nos fue mucho
más fácil avanzar en población infantil
que el resto la vacuna parece ser que
latinoamérica tiene una mayor aceptación
en que los niños sean vacunados según un
estudio publicado por la revista
internacional daxing el 68% de los
padres en américa latina y el caribe
afirmó sentirse seguro con vacunar a sus
hijos ya que estamos hablando de
vacunación veamos las cifras globales
cómo avanza la inoculación en el mundo
así es como están las cosas el número de
dosis administradas a nivel mundial
supera ya las 9 mil 758 millones de
dosis el país con la mayor cantidad de
dosis administra por cada 100.000
habitantes scuba son más de 292 mil
dosis por cada 100.000 habitantes en
este país caribeño cuba ha liderado la
vacunación regional además lo hace con
biológicos desarrollados por científicos
locales siendo así el único país de
américa latina que ha desarrollado una
vacuna propia contra el kobe 19
segundo bloque de nuestro recorrido por
el continente americano vamos a ir hasta
ecuador ahí hay un considerable aumento
de los casos quito la capital está en
alerta roja y está avanzando también la
vacunación para los menores de edad
gustavo ortega nos cuenta más
hola qué tan santiago ecuador vuelve al
semáforo de restricciones sanitarias
para calificar cada ciudad según el
nivel de contagio para intentar frenar
la variante omicron en el país algunos
especialistas consideran que ecuador
vive una nueva explosión de contagios
con esta variante omicron de igual forma
se experimenta el pico más alto de
rebrotes desde el inicio la pandemia lo
que representa un incremento del 300 por
ciento desde la segunda semana del mes
de enero del año 2022 según cifras
oficiales la tasa de positividad también
se incrementó del 10 al 46 por ciento en
la población en el caso de quito la
capital ecuatoriana fue declarada en
alerta roja el promedio de ocupación de
unidades de cuidados intensivos es del
68 por ciento y de 90 por ciento en
hospitalización en este hospital el 90
por ciento de sus 180 camas de
hospitalización están ocupadas igual que
la totalidad de sus 18 camas de unidades
de cuidados intensivos en los centros de
salud vuelven las filas para acceder
para buscar así cuidados médicos en los
exteriores la reducción de aforos a
nivel nacional para acceder al
supermercado entidades bancarias
gimnasios o restaurantes entre otros fue
reducido en un promedio del 50 por
ciento además se suspendieron las clases
presenciales a nivel nacional el 70% al
sector público en que deberá volver al
teletrabajo ante el acelerado incremento
de casos las autoridades buscan
apresurar la vacunación que contabiliza
hasta la fecha 84 por ciento de la
población vacunada con dos dosis
mientras que a partir del 3 de febrero
se iniciará la inoculación en niños a
partir de los 3 años de edad en algunos
centros de salud se habilitan nuevas
camas y se instalan carpas para atención
a los pacientes gracias gustavo desde
quito y bolivia alcanzó ya los 20 mil
fallecidos por cuenta del cob y 19 este
país prepara también el regreso a las
clases con algunas particularidades
meriva acá desde la ciudad de la paz
tienen los detalles adelante mary
bolivia está cursando la cuarta ola de
coronavirus y lo hace en medio de una
fuerte polémica luego de que el gobierno
de luisa se decidiera suspender mientras
dure la emergencia sanitaria la
obligatoriedad de presentar el pase
sanitario en lugares donde exista
aglomeración de personas los opositores
han criticado esta decisión pues cuando
se necesita que la gente esté vacunada
es justamente durante emergencia
sanitaria y de hecho de inmediato
después del anuncio de la suspensión los
centros de vacunación prácticamente se
han vaciado en días pasados se
observaban largas filas de gente
tratando de conseguir la vacuna lo cual
ha cambiado y ahora hay poca gente
buscando la inoculación durante la
cuarta ola bolivia ha presentado una
explosión de casos llegando a registrar
más de 14.000 en un solo día
actualmente están registrando 10.000
casos diarios y el epicentro de la
pandemia que ha sido santacruz ha
empezado la des escalada pero hay
ciudades como por ejemplo la paz que
continúan en el ascenso de casos de kobe
19 en cuanto a fallecidos debo decirles
que el país ha superado los 20.000 y de
hecho cada día se presentan más de 50
personas muertas por causas de el
coronavirus en ese contexto el gobierno
prepara el regreso a clases pero con una
particularidad ha dejado que sean los
directores de cada unidad educativa a
los que decidan la modalidad es decir
y definirán si van a volver a clases de
manera presencial virtual o
semipresencial venezuela viene
presentando hasta 2.300 casos de
contagios en un espacio de 24 horas así
lo confirmaron las autoridades de ese
país la vacunación también fue
habilitada para los colegios y para las
farmacias privadas
daniela zambrano desde caracas nos
cuenta más en la última semana en
venezuela se ha registrado el mayor
número de casos por kobe 19 desde el
inicio de la pandemia la vicepresidenta
del tse rodríguez daba cuenta de más de
2300 casos en menos de 24 horas una
cifra que antes no se reportaba esto
debido al avance de la variante un
micrón en el país expertos ya advertían
que iban aumentar los casos luego que el
pasado primero de noviembre el gobierno
flexibilizará las medidas impuestas por
la cuarentena permitiendo reanudar la
actividad comercial y levantando
prácticamente todas las restricciones se
ha iniciado una jornada de vacunación en
los colegios también en las redes
farmacias privadas la tercera dosis
aunque en el país hay personas que han
asegurado todavía no han recibido
según el propio nicolás maduro más del
95 por ciento de la población ya estaría
totalmente vacunado contra kobe 19 pero
ha sido una cifra cuestionada por
expertos médicos infectólogos que
aseguran que es mucho menor incluso la
organización panamericana de la salud
reportaba que a principios de año en
venezuela la cifra de vacunados ha
alcanzado el 40% de la población desde
el inicio de la pandemia en venezuela se
han registrado más de 450 mil casos de
kobe 19 y lamentablemente más de 5000
personas fallecidas grasas
daniela por este reporte desde la ciudad
de caracas la variante omicron ya es la
causa del 90% de los casos de contagio
en la ciudad de lima que es la capital
de perú en este país cuatro ministros
del gabinete de gobierno ya dieron
positivo por kobe 19 francisco zacarías
nos cuenta más desde la capital peruana
hola santiago pero afronta la tercera
ola de la pandemia del coi 19 con el
pico más alto de contagios en los
últimos días los casos se han triplicado
llegando a más de 200.000 según algunos
expertos el ministerio de salud por su
parte advierte el incremento del 50 por
ciento de fallecidos entre la primera y
segunda semana de enero mientras tanto
el último reporte de vigilancia genómica
realizado por el instituto nacional de
salud revela que la variante o micro es
responsable del 90% de contagio se anima
mientras que al interior del país su
predominancia va en rápido ascenso la
infección por kobe 19 también ha llegado
al interior del gobierno del presidente
pedro castillo cuatro de sus ministros
entre ellos el ministro de salud
hernando ceballos dieron positivo al
coronavirus pero esto no desanima a las
autoridades que continúan con la
inmunización en el perú este país ha
aplicado más de 54.7 millones de vacunas
cifra que representa al 90 por ciento de
su población objetivo y se alista a
iniciar la vacunación de niños de 5 a 11
en lima hay diversas regiones de esta
nación este grupo etario reúne a más de
42 millones de menores las autoridades
sanitarias advierten que omicron tiene
una clara incidencia en la población
pediátrica y quieren evitar en perú
casos de niños con complicaciones
severas
antonio gutiérrez el secretario general
de la onu afirmó que la meta de
vacunación para el 2021 no fue alcanzada
y que todavía hay muchos países
rezagados estas fueron sus palabras
escuchemos
el otoño pasado la organización mundial
de la salud dio a conocer una estrategia
para vacunar al 40 por ciento de las
personas en todos los países a fines del
año pasado y al 70% a mediados de este
año no estamos ni cerca de estos
objetivos las tasas de vacunación en los
países de altos ingresos son
vergonzosamente siete veces más altos
que en los países africanos y
necesitamos equidad de vacunas ahora
todos los países y todos los fabricantes
deben priorizar el suministro de vacunas
a kóvacs y apoyar la producción local de
pruebas vacunas y tratamientos en todo
el mundo
round wall y nuestro último bloque por
este recorrido por el continente nos
lleva hasta uruguay chile y a brasil en
este último país los contagios debido a
la variante omicron han aumentado cerca
de un 300% y hay escasez de test ahora
sí valeria sacones desde río de janeiro
nos da un panorama de la situación
veamos
en brasil la hora de omicron está acá
esta semana el país
registrando en tan solo 24 horas más de
205 mil contagios también la media
semanal se sitúa por encima de los 110
mil contagios registrados lo que supone
un aumento del 300 73 por ciento en las
últimas dos semanas ya hay que dejar
claro una cosa estos datos están muy por
debajo de la realidad por dos razones el
país se ha quedado corto detesta tanto
en las farmacias como en los centros
médicos privados y públicos con lo cual
no todas las personas contagiadas pueden
tener un diagnóstico y además el 10 de
diciembre el sistema
del ministerio deja
y las autoridades sanitarias no fueran
no aumentan con la misma velocidad que
los contagios la media semanal es de 273
muertos con picos de unos 350 muy lejos
de los más de 4000 muertos diarios que
vimos aquí el pasado mes de abril aún
así la media de crecimiento de las
muertes preocupa a las autoridades
sanitarias porque las últimas dos
semanas se ha registrado un aumento del
114 por ciento
problemas
bares y restaurantes llenos y en la
población cansada
direcciones que quiere simplemente
d
en el cielo
en febrero hay una buena noticia ha
arrancado la vacunación de los niños de
5 a 11 años tras semanas de polémicas y
mucha resistencia por parte del
presidente de jair bolsonaro y miren
ustedes en uruguay también escasean los
tests y los servicios de salud han
comenzado a mostrar señales de
saturación en pleno pico de la llegada
de turistas extranjeros por la temporada
de verano a ese país karina dalmás desde
punta del este que es el epicentro de la
industria turística uruguaya nos amplia
más en su reporte
uruguay experimenta una nueva ola de
casos de coronavirus en la mayoría de
los contagios se deben a la variante
omicron por momentos los servicios de
salud se están viendo
colapsados las autoridades sanitarias
indicaron también que existe una escasez
de tests de antígenos todo esto en el
medio de una temporada estival en un
país donde el turismo es una de las
principales
industrias se vieron restaurantes
cerrados eventos sociales y culturales
suspendidos gran influencia de turistas
en su mayoría argentinos sin embargo no
se alcanzó lógicamente en los números de
turistas previo a la pandemia
el gobierno cambió la modalidad de
cuarentena y también de testeo para
asintomáticos al tiempo que exhortó a
las empresas públicas a realizar 30 días
de teletrabajo esto fue cuestionado por
algunos expertos que indicaron que la
medida llegó muy tarde entretanto los
menores de entre 5 y 11 años están
recibiendo la vacunación también de
forma gratuita en el país el 50 por
ciento de los habilitados ya se ha
inscripto o ha recibido la misma en
uruguay el 80% de la población se
recibió al menos una dosis de las
vacunas el refuerzo de vacunación
también estuvo disponible en forma
gratuita para turistas entretanto en
este marco el carnaval más largo del
mundo inició en uruguay eso sí con
cambios de recintos en algunos lugares
se suspendieron actividades y en el otro
se está exigiendo el certificado de
vacunación para participar de la misma
y vamos a finalizar en chile único país
del continente que ha comenzado la
inoculación de la cuarta dosis leonardo
honores nos cuenta más desde santiago la
variante omicron está poniendo en jaque
la trazabilidad en chile el seguimiento
de la pandemia es la principal
preocupación de las autoridades de salud
en los últimos días se han contabilizado
12 mil 500 casos eso en promedio un
fuerte aumento en las últimas semanas
también hay que considerar que estamos
viviendo el proceso de vacaciones la
cantidad de viajeros y justamente tanto
por vía terrestre como por vía aérea es
un elemento adicional que ha generado
una preocupación para las autoridades
del ministerio de salud en chile- además
se ha iniciado el proceso de vacunación
con la cuarta dosis que en este caso
está privilegiando a las personas que
tienen inmunodeficiencia y también por
supuesto al personal de la salud allí se
están apostando las principales
preocupaciones los ojos de las
autoridades justamente están dando
cuenta de esa sensibilidad otro de los
temas que preocupa es a futuro los
próximos meses ya el proceso lectivo los
distintos colegios las universidades las
escuelas tuvieron dos años de mayor
estrés la idea es que esto no se repita
durante este periodo 2022 pero no hay
ninguna certeza de que esto así ocurra
es todo por el día de hoy nos vemos la
próxima semana en kobe 19 la semana en
américa sigan en sintonía de france 24
[Música]